[Music]
foreign
and I am so excited to be co-teaching
the Workshop web design for shiny
developers this year at posicomp 2023.
I'm David
today I want to talk to you about the
workshop we are going to give with my
against a deposit conference at the end
of the year
I think this course is important for
shiny developers but in this video I'm
going to distill it to my top three the
first one is self-sufficiency in design
most applications developers work hand
in hand with designers to create
applications but in this course we're
going to give you that autonomy to feel
comfortable in your design decisions and
create an app all by yourself
and this Workshop we'll start from the
very beginning from the user
requirements you learn how to deal with
them and how to translate them into
mockups you leverage way of framing to
In the End come up with a solution
that's satisfied the client the second
skill is user experience so not only
will we Define what that means but we'll
give you the tips and tricks as well as
tools to make sure that you're talking
to your end users and making sure that
the app Sparks joy for the people using
your app on a daily basis
in this Workshop you'll learn how to
deal with these kind of things for
instance your theme for the end users
what do the end user want to see when
there is an error well do the end user
want to see when where is the
computation
the last and what I think is probably
the most the most important skill that
that color typography layout using the
nomenclature and code in R so this
course is already geared to the language
that you know and love and you will
leave with code ready to go
I'm convinced by the end of the workshop
you will accumulate a lot of different
best practices around web design
so you can quickly determine what is a
good UI what is a bad device
and the good news doesn't matter if
you're a good or developer doesn't
matter your level in Shady development
it's just about soft skills so that you
can seamlessly translate blue skills
into your previous work thanks so much
for watching this video and I hope to
see you at the conference thank you so
much and hope to see you there
[Music]